[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Street food at
covered markets in coronavirus.
It doesn't sound like
a recipe for success.
TIM HAYWARD: We've come to
South London's Brixton Village
to see how the restaurants
here are coping.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Small
independents run tight margins
at the best of times,
so how did they
respond when the pandemic hit?
TIM HAYWARD: How can they
survive a post-lockdown future?
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Tim, we've done
the Michelin star restaurant.
We've seen the local
neighbourhood restaurant.
We're here at Brixton
Village Market today.
Quite different scale to the
places we've been so far.
What's it going to be
like for these guys?
It must be really challenging.
TIM HAYWARD: It's going to
be pretty awful for them.
This isn't just a matter
of getting balance.
Small, independent operations
are absolutely the majority,
the backbone of this sector.
And the other thing
that most civilians
don't get, to be honest, is
how tight their margins are.
Everybody in the restaurant
industry-- yeah, your margins
are tight.
That's fine.
That's great when you've
got a GBP 6,000,000
operation in West End.
These guys' margins are--
we're really talking pennies.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: But it'll
be interesting to see now
whether those people who
are stuck at home, working
from home for the
foreseeable future--
whether they're going to
come to the rescue for a lot
these small, independent guys.
TIM HAYWARD: And as we're
proving with everything
we've done so far, it's
about the relationship
to the local community.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: All right.
Let's go see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The market's general manager,
Diana, shows us around.
The restaurants
here rub shoulder
to shoulder with grocers,
butchers, fishmongers,
and retailers.
TIM HAYWARD: I've never
met a female fishmonger.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: And they were
all given a three-month rent
break during lockdown.
TIM HAYWARD: We're
also interested to hear
that this place is
Grade II listed,
meaning it has to
be preserved not
for its architectural beauty,
but for its cultural diversity.
DIANA NABAGEREKA:
Our responsibility
as a custodian for the market
is to ensure that the retail mix
is retained.
So there must always be
a Latin American butcher.
There must always be a
Caribbean fishmonger.
There must always be Esme, who
sells natural and organic herbs
that she ships over
from the Caribbean.
So it's those sorts of tenants
that have to be preserved.
TIM HAYWARD: So this is
written into your listing.
DIANA NABAGEREKA: It's bizarre.
TIM HAYWARD: There's
nothing you can do about it.
DIANA NABAGEREKA: Sorry.
I say bizarre.
It's actually beautiful.
I've never seen a listing
so splendid and bizarre.
TIM HAYWARD: So what
if I'm a McDonald's?
Can I come?
DIANA NABAGEREKA: No, thank you.
This space really cultivates
individuality and just
independent entrepreneurship.
They get it wrong
a lot of the time,
but through that
comes experiences
and just really, really
great, great tenant mixes.
TIM HAYWARD: Hey, Brian.
You all right?
DANIEL GARRAHAN:
Brian definitely
has the entrepreneurial spirit.
He says he was panicking
when the country locked down
and the restaurant closed.
But he's not only survived.
He's thrived.
TIM HAYWARD: The rent
break, [INAUDIBLE] scheme,
and VAT reduction
were a big help.
But he was ready to do anything.
BRIAN DANCLAIR: For instance,
this is how I will plan.
I bought a lawnmower,
just in case
I couldn't work any
further, work anymore,
to go and cut grass.
[LAUGHTER]
TIM HAYWARD: You put your face
on the sauce bottle, damn it.
All this going on,
and yet, still,
in the back of your mind,
there was a point in there
when you were thinking, I might
have to go mow people's lawns.
BRIAN DANCLAIR: I have
to do anything that's
necessary to be relevant,
to make money for my family,
to feed my family, to pay my
mortgage, everything like that.
You know what I mean?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GARRAHAN:
Instead of mowing lawns,
he's used social
media to stay in touch
with the local community, ramped
up takeaway, and streamlined
his menu to save costs.
BRIAN DANCLAIR: Two things--
Brexit and, as well as the
COVID, the prices of some items
have gone up.
So of course, we had to take
that component out and focus
on getting them just right,
to be on pace, to be focused.
You know what I mean?
And that was the idea, and
that worked fantastic for us.
I changed the prices a bit.
The rum punch, for
instance-- we were
doing a big and a small one.
We are doing just
the big ones now.
Anytime you have
situations like this,
something always
comes out of it,
and you have to really be
positive and get it done.
That's how we look at it.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: So you look
at it as an opportunity.
There's always
opportunity like this.
You take this as
a learning curve.
Improve yourself.
TIM HAYWARD: They
have the resources,
and they have the agility
to actually do that.
DANIEL GARRAHAN:
There's that word again.
Agility.
BRIAN DANCLAIR:
Agility's important.
You have to be agile
in this business.
If you can't manoeuvre, and
if you're just stagnant,
you get beaten.
So this is how we were able to
move tables around and change
the structure of the restaurant.
If we had to change this
restaurant to takeaway tonight,
we could do it.
Boom.
Easily.
TIM HAYWARD: If agility is
one word that comes up a lot,
community is another.
DANIEL GARRAHAN:
Moto runs Okan, who's
been serving up down-to-earth
Japanese food for years.
When COVID hit, she
didn't know what to do.
TIM HAYWARD: What
happened when COVID hit?
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Oh, gosh, yeah.
Completely stopped, and just
thinking, what should I do?
When should I reopen?
Should I open the
takeaway or not?
Or I need to save my
staff, keep safe, so I
shouldn't open takeaway, even?
And so just going around,
around, but there's no answer.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: When the
restaurant did reopen,
it was the community that
gave her the encouragement
to keep going.
MOTO PRIESTMAN: From the local
people saying, "How are you?"
And, "Are you open?"
"Well done."
These repeating,
repeating, hearing
the words and warm
feeling, I thought, OK.
I think Okan udon
going to burst.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Sure
you're optimistic?
MOTO PRIESTMAN: [LAUGHS]
DANIEL GARRAHAN: As
optimistic as you can be.
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Yeah.
I think that's
always my character,
but COVID-19 made
me, definitely,
very weak and nervous.
TIM HAYWARD: Is it
fair to say you feel
supported by the community?
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Yeah.
Not necessarily, they
come to buy from us.
Some people will buy from
us, get the dish from us.
But some people--
I've seen them, maybe,
over the last five, six
years, almost once a week
or once a month.
We don't know names each
other, but we recognise faces.
TIM HAYWARD: You're
saying community--
it affects your mental health.
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Yeah.
TIM HAYWARD: It
makes you strong.
That's tremendous at that level.
That is so exciting
to find that.
But what I love
about restaurants
is the soul and the
emotion and the feeling
of being loved--
true hospitality.
And what you're saying is
that that's being rewarded.
Those are the ones who
are going to survive this.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: The
fall in the market
has plummeted as much
as 90% during lockdown,
but it's started to return
to more normal levels.
TIM HAYWARD: Diana says the
one positive from the pandemic
is how Britain's old
and new residents have
been brought together in the
same space at the same time.
DIANA NABAGEREKA: I've
always seen this market
as having an old Brixton and
a new Brixton that visit it.
The old Brixton has
lived here for decades
and slowly started to
move out of Brixton,
perhaps living in
Croydon, living in Purley,
because they, perhaps, may
not be able to afford it.
But they still come here to get
their produce and their goods.
They come in in the morning.
They use it as their community
space, and they enjoy it.
Then they go home at 6 o'clock.
New Brixton leaves
Brixton at 8:00 AM.
They go into Victoria.
They go into Oxford Circus.
They go to [INAUDIBLE]
Street and work, and then
come back at 6:00 PM.
So when old Brixton
leaves, new Brixton
comes and then enjoys
our nighttime economy.
What we learnt was, actually,
when new Brixton wasn't allowed
to go to work and
had to work at home,
they were then spending
their time shopping and using
the space like old Brixton.
So there's now-- yeah, Henry and
Katie walk around the market,
where previously, it was
Patrice and Ronald, honestly.
Yeah, and I really love that.
And they walk side by side now.
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Oh,
you've got own chopsticks.
TIM HAYWARD: Of course.
Thank you.
MOTO PRIESTMAN: Amazing.
I've never seen.
Wow.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Well, first
thing I'm going to say to him
is, not only am I
impressed that you've
got your face mask with you.
You've also got
your own chopsticks.
This is commitment to the
COVID security course.
TIM HAYWARD: No,
it's just easier.
I think more people should
carry their own kit.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: The
one thing I would
say, having spoken to a few of
the food vendors in this place,
is how heartwarming it
is that most of them
are telling a really
positive story.
They're obviously at the
sharp end of this thing,
but most of them seem,
actually, quite optimistic.
TIM HAYWARD: So these guys
do have a positive outlook,
because their landlord has
looked to them and said,
OK, now.
We've got to keep
these people here.
We've got to help them out.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: They'd given
them this three-month break,
of course.
TIM HAYWARD: They've
given them a break.
They will continue to
get the rent breaks.
They're already predisposed
to help small and diverse
businesses in the first place.
And here, this is the definition
of what London community should
really be about.
It's massively diverse.
It's warm.
It's friendly.
It's diverse by class.
It's diverse by culture,
by ethnicity, and it works.
DANIEL GARRAHAN: Well, look.
If these noodles are
anything to go by,
I hope the community
does stick with it,
and we get to enjoy
another bowl sometime soon.
TIM HAYWARD: Absolutely.
DANIEL GARRAHAN:
Mmm, that was good.